tell me about this is em this is your
new music this is me the semi my
initials this is the result of a big
change that I made my life last year I
saw that my career which had peaked in
the 90s really you know really had that
big long worth a lot of other music and
the music industry that was having a
really big you know boom in the 90s and
then I saw it just kind of plateau and
level out
so last year I cleaned house I got new
management new representation and all
sorts and I said let's put our heads
together what does Melissa efforts need
to do as a brand in 2014-2015 and on how
how do i monetize that which I know is
out in the world that is a good feeling
about myself in my music how can I make
that work for me so I got off my record
label I'd been on for 25 years Island
Records I started my own record label
I got a distribution deal on this album
so I have marketing I have publicity and
branding and everything all in one
company so this is my brand new me in
charge me as the entrepreneur album that
I'm putting out it actually came out
explain a little bit for people that may
not be familiar with the record industry
the music business what was it like in
1993 compare it to what's going on now
the record business industry the
recording industry was built on the
model of they would find an artist in
the 50 60 70 s 80s even and what
happened in the 80s was you know they
would find an artist that would sign
them you you would be bound to them
everything to your voice would belong to
the record company you couldn't go sing
on anyone elses song without their
permission you couldn't do anything with
your voice they owned your voice and
then it started to fall in on itself
with digital if you want the song come
to my window for this TV show or for a
movie
you would call Island Records and you
would ask them and you would pay them
because they own the mess they own that
recording I don't own it I don't really
make any money on that recording tell us
about the latest musical endeavor
because that also brings together a lot
of different people
yes well the new model is that I don't
have this million dollar budget upfront
I used to write the songs and I'd go in
with a producer I'd pay him some money
I paid the band some money two weeks a
studio and you make a record now since I
don't have that upfront money I go to
the producer who now because of
Technology has a much smaller studio it
can all be done much more economically
you can make you can make a record in
your bedroom now basically as far as the
music I'm wondering if you can describe
how that is infused with your own
personal life let's say over the last
decade or so because you've had to face
some very significant health issues with
cancer how does that come out in the
music I'll tell you I learned a long
time ago that the songs that come from
my experience that come from my myself
what I know those are the songs that
touch people the more personal I would
get the more universal it would be
you've also not only been open about as
you mentioned your cancer but you've
been also very open about your own
personal life and about getting married
congratulations you got married this
year what if you could just speak a
little bit about that and one of the
trends they you hope is no longer a
trend but just the sort of everyday
situation in the United States same-sex
marriage same-sex marriage it's
something that twenty years ago
I that was it was a dream that was a
sort of a strange dream what what that
mean I had a wife we married we weren't
ever going to get married we were
alternative you know this wasn't what it
was and the and the older we got and the
the families we started creating the
children we had we realized as a
community that with the
do need the same rice the same
protections that are amazing country and
affords us there's the possibility maybe
you have something on Broadway
yes now that's a dream of mine I've
couple years ago I did like a week of
American Idiot and it was just such a
delight and I love Broadway it's just
it's a very special place and I hope to
create with my wife my wife I'm getting
used to saying my wife with my wife who
is she's creative miss Jackie and I'm
amazing writer and she's the creator of
Nurse Jackie very popular television
she's done quite a lot her and I are
creating a Broadway musical now it is
definitely in the backseat to her you
know three shows that she's working on
and my album so it is been sitting there
and it might be a couple more years
before it actually comes about but it's
it's in the pipeline and I really look
forward to it all right one other thing
that's in the pipeline literally I guess
and figuratively right so you you fill
in the blanks for everybody this came
about because of the I believe the
chemotherapy that you were experiencing
when you were fighting cancer yes I had
a choice at the time I was in California
Medical Marijuana State I had a choice
of you know all the pharmaceuticals that
I could have taken for pain and
depression and and all these things and
which had side effects and more pills or
I have a choice of of using the herb
cannabis and using it for pain relief
for my appetite for everything it kept
me very healthy during chemotherapy I
highly recommend anyone who is
undergoing this to really look into the
medical signs of it I believe this is a
huge opportunity a huge business a huge
market I'm going to you know you're
going to see my name with a lot of these
things I actually have a wine that's
coming out really it's a it's a cannabis
infused wine which actually tastes
amazing and so we're working on that
it's there's a lot of legal of course
stuff that's just you know amazing but
once that settles down I really look
forward to you bringing this to the
world in a in a not scary way and not a
drug you know the way it used to go out
long way it's not that anymore this is a
this is an American business that really
needs a lot of help